[Applause]
[Music]
did harry styles spit on chris pine
let's just get straight to it yeah it's
this supposed saliva spurt that has fans
asking that question the viral moment
going down at the venice film festival
online onlookers convinced the singer
sent a big wet one sliding onto pine's
lap
but chris's rep is here to clean up the
mess telling e.t it's a ridiculous story
calling it quote a complete fabrication
and the result of an odd online illusion
that is clearly deceiving and allows for
foolish speculation
that statement only got gossipers
salivating for more intel on the
exchange though i can't even tell you
it happened at the premiere for harry
and chris's film don't worry darling a
movie that's been shadowed by tabloid
tales of what went down on its set
once inside the screening harry's seen
bending over then the star trek star
freezes mid clap looks at his lap and
laughs
[Music]
one fan tweeted so what's the verdict
here did harry spit on chris pine what
happened on that movie set bro
while another jokingly says what is
potus doing to protect our americans
abroad chris pine from foreign threats
harry styles
then there's styles supporters writing
it all off as fan fiction one user
sharing this theory chris pine just
wondered where his sunglasses were after
the applause and he zoned out like he's
been doing all day and realized it's in
his lap so i am sorry to say harry
styles did not spit on him
the wrong guy
chris's rep tells et there is nothing
but respect between these two men and
any suggestion otherwise is a blatant
attempt to create drama that simply does
not exist and two years ago when filming
wrapped on don't worry darling chris had
nothing but nice things to say about his
co-star harry styles is an absolute
delight he's the one of the most
professional people i've ever met
couldn't be kinder more gracious i mean
really i was like
i was stunned by this this kid he's
just off the charts cool
spit gate is just a drop in the flood of
drama bursting from behind the scenes of
this film the biggest being rumored
tension between leading lady florence
pugh and director olivia wilde that may
or may not have started on set because
florence was upset about olivia getting
with harry who replaced original star
shia labeouf under still mysterious
circumstances
boys and their toys at least we know
they're getting work done
olivia couldn't escape the inevitable a
reporter asking point blank about the
rumors at the film's venice press
conference
which florence skipped citing scheduling
issues
can you just clear the air and address
if there's been a falling out there and
if so why because it's something that
people are discussing
florence is a force and we are so
grateful that she's able to make it
tonight despite being in production on
dune as for all the endless tabloid
gossip and all the noise out there i
mean the internet feeds itself i don't
feel the need to contribute i think it's
sufficiently well nourished
but fast forward to the red carpet and
the internet continued to feed
dissecting the cast's every move after
florence arrived you'll see chris is
carefully positioned between olivia and
florence the 26 year old avoiding any
interaction with both harry and olivia
inside though spit moment aside things
seemed more cordial the cast celebrating
together florence even clapping for
olivia during a seven-minute standing
ovation after the screening
shooting out was wonderful olivia is
very clear about what she wants the
aesthetic of the movie is beautiful
the story is so compelling and so fun
and so dark and twisted florence is an
incredible actress i can't speak more
highly ever this is the second time i've
worked with her and
um
every time i work with her i say i have
to meet your parents because
however they raised you they should be
teaching seminars it's just a great cast
a great group again you know a life is
short so hopefully you get a chance to
make good art with people you really
enjoy and
i've been really really lucky in that
regard
[Music]
you